- Hi everyone,
welcome to Khan Academy's
daily homeroom livestream.
For those of you all who
do not know what this is,
this is something that we thought of
when we started seeing
mass school closures
and we know that people
are gonna be at home,
socially distanced.
And obviously Khan Academy,
we saw ourselves as,
it's our duty to step up
in this time of closure.
So a lot of our resources
are the way that many
of y'all might be able to keep learning
or have your children or
your students keep learning.
But we've also trying
to do other supports.
We thought it'd be just fun
to have a synchronous way
to have interesting
conversations between ourselves
to bring on interesting guests
from all over the world
on all sorts of topics.
I am doing an interesting experiment today
that we should all have a
growth mindset about things.
I have my phone leaned against
my computer right over here,
so that I can simultaneously
do this on Instagram.
So normally we have some
technology that Philippe has found
(laughs) that allows us
to do this on Facebook
and YouTube simultaneously, but
now we have added Instagram,
so I'm saying hi to all of the
folks on Instagram as well.
So today's topic is going
to be really interesting.
It's going to be
graduation and life advice,
and you can almost view this is like
interactive graduation address,
which is frankly better than
just me sitting at a podium
and giving you something
that you might not remember
for the next 20 minutes.
But before we break into the Q&A,
start thinking of those
life advice questions
that you would like, and
we have team members,
I'm gonna be looking at the Instagram
and then our team members are
going to be helping me out
with YouTube and Facebook.
I do want to give a special
thanks to several corporations
that have stepped up over
the last several weeks,
especially with the COVID crisis.
Khan Academy is a not-for-profit.
We can only exist because
of philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself,
and from corporations
and foundations, and folks like
Bank of America, Google.org,
AT&T.
Fastly and Novartis have stepped up
just in the last few months
when they realized that our
costs were going even higher,
(laughs) because our
usage, our server costs,
our usage is about two and a half,
three X of what it typically is.
We're trying to accelerate
all programs forward.
So thank you to all of them.
And once again, if you're
in a position to donate,
every dollar matters,
it helps us to show sure of confidence.
It helps us reach that many more folks
who otherwise would not
be able to have access
to some form of a
free-world class education,
or teachers who would not have
access to tools like this.
So with that,
I would love to take any
questions that you have.
And I already see a couple of questions.
Oh, actually it looks like my team
is also scanning Instagram,
so this is super helpful for me.
So from Instagram, at
SRG underscore 19 asks,
what is your favorite
memory from high school?
You're taking me back.
All right, let me see.
I don't know if it's my favorite memory,
but I could probably
think of some memories.
I remember there was a day
I was in student council
and we were, in student
council in high school
you paint those pep rally
type banners and stuff,
and there was, someone had
forgot to close the yellow paint,
and I wanted to make a point that like,
when you don't close the yellow paint,
the yellow paint all dries up.
And so I was like,
"Look, this is all dry."
And I did this and I was
like, "Look how dry it is."
And then it wasn't dry.
And so the yellow paint,
that was a good memory.
It helped me to take myself
a little less seriously,
(laughs) because the
universe was conspiring
to keep me from being too self-righteous.
Let's see other great
memories from high school.
I mean there's great memories.
I remember we went on a
camping trip, my senior year.
That was great, and we got lost.
So it's always those memories
where it's a little bit of
an adventure, that's nice.
There's some things I cringe at,
some of you all may or may not know that,
I did give the graduation address
at my high school graduation
and I was a little bit angsty.
I was also, by my senior
year, I was not in a band,
but my sophomore year I was a lead singer
in heavy metal band.
And so I had that little angsty in me.
And so at graduation, I felt the need,
and I cringe a little bit about it now,
but I guess it is a memory
to make a statement.
So the morning of graduation,
my friend and myself,
we actually snuck into the auditorium
where the graduation is going to happen
and we put a guitar
under the diploma table.
And so when I went up to give a speech,
I said, "I think it would
be better if I sang this."
And so I took the guitar out
from underneath the diploma table.
I still remember the look
on my principal's face,
it was just like horror (laughs)
and frankly half the crowd, and I sang.
So, I cringe on it now.
I wouldn't do that today, and
I wouldn't recommend it today.
But it was it was novel.
So I'll try to think of
more and more memories
as we go through this session.
But that's a good question.
So from Instagram, @leanmarvelous asks,
how old were you when you realized
that helping others to learn
was a passion of yours?
Great question, Lean Marvelous.
And if you see me looking back and forth,
I'm looking at my computer screen
and I'm looking at the Instagram screen
so that I'm making eye
contact with everyone.
So I realized I really
enjoyed tutoring folks.
It was actually around that
same time in high school,
and actually that even jog some
other really great memories
but it might not surprise
folks that I was the captain
or the president of the math club.
(chuckles)
That is cool.
It was called new alpha theater.
I don't know if that's a thing
where you go to high school.
But as part of it, we
wanted to do service,
and we figured a valuable service
would be to tutor our peers.
And so we used to do this
afterschool tutoring thing
for our peers and a lot of
kids actually showed up for it.
And it was then that I realized
that if you give students,
if you give anyone one-on-one attention,
give them a chance to fill in the gaps,
that they're really capable
of learning almost anything.
And I saw it before my
eyes, a lot of my friends,
or even people I didn't
know who were C students
who thought they weren't good at math
when they just got a
little bit of attention,
they were able to catch up
and do whatever they needed to do.
So that was the first time I
realized I really enjoyed it.
Then when I was in college,
I did a little bit of that as well.
There was a local school, had budget cuts.
And so they needed some
more, I guess you could say,
volunteer teachers or teacher assistance.
And so myself and my roommate,
we went and volunteered.
This was in Brookline,
Massachusetts, and really enjoyed it.
I realized that I had no
classroom management skills.
(laughs)
A lot of your teachers can
appreciate how important that is,
I didn't at the time.
There were moments where
I had some fifth graders
standing on top of a table
and I had to spend a little
bit more time than I'd like
telling them to get off.
But I realized that that
was intriguing to me.
And I think it was after my junior year,
I got a fellowship to work on software.
I had applied for it, work
on educational software
for students with
attention deficit disorder.
It was called an aeleron to
fellowship at my undergrad.
And that was the first time I
started writing some software
and seeing if this could
be of help to folks.
And then the life took
over, pragmatism took over
and graduating from college,
I had a a reasonable
amount of debt and I said,
"I need to make some money,
maybe help out the family a little bit."
So I went into tack, which
I also enjoy my background.
My undergraduate degrees were
in math and computer science.
And many of you all know the story.
I then go to business school,
I become a hedge fund analyst,
but then while that was
happening, my cousins needed help.
And so it kindled that same
joy for the subject matter
and for being able to help
folks especially family members.
And so that's what got me on the track
and the more I did it,
the more that I saw gains
in my cousins and other folks that I knew.
And frankly, the more that I got letters
from random people on the Internet
(chuckles) saying that it helping them.
I don't think there's
anything special about me.
I think anyone would find
that incredibly rewarding,
and it was a little bit addictive,
you start to realize how
much more joyful that is
when you get a letter
from someone in Indonesia
saying that you helped them
get back to going to college
versus you get a slightly larger bonus
at your hedge fund job,
and you realize that
maybe this is what you
could do for a living.
So it was just, I guess
you could say signs
that were showing up
in my life throughout.
And at some point you
just have to pay attention
to those signs (laughs)
they'd keep trying to make themselves
a little bit more visible.
So let's see, from Instagram,
a lot of questions from Instagram,
we should do this more regularly,
have a livestream all of the above.
Andy Chavez, Oh, it disappeared, said,
"How do you learn from failure ..."
Oh, there it goes.
"How do you learn from failure?"
So, I think the first
step is to just recognize
that the failure is not a,
it's not a judgment on you.
I think so many times we confuse ourselves
with our thoughts, with our labels,
that society is putting
on and things like grades,
or you failed, or you didn't
... That's kind of a label
or some extrinsic thing
that happens to you
and to realize that's not yourself,
and to realize that those
are the moments of growth.
The very fact that you're
failing is a good sign.
It's a sign that you're pushing yourself
out of your comfort zone,
you're not just resting on your laurels.
And and if you reflect on that failure,
and I recently met a teacher
who likes to use the phrase "fail forward"
So if you reflect on
that failure and you say,
"Okay, what can I learn from it
so that maybe next time I try,
I have a little bit lower
chance of at least failing
in that way."
Then I'm making progress.
That's how you grow as a human being.
And this mystery that we all
live, (chuckles) whole life,
and it is really a mystery,
all I can think of the best
thing to do is to keep on going,
keep on growing, keep on failing
and keep on learning from that.
And when you do that, and
actually when you learn,
when you see that you can
get onto the other side
of failure, even once, I think it was a,
we had Alberta Carvallo, who's
superintendent of Miami Dade,
he said something about that.
The first time that you do
something a little bit scary
and you even fail a little bit,
but then you power through it
and you realize that you can
get to the other side of it
that's when you realize that's a muscle.
And then next time when
you see an obstacle,
when you see the failure you're like,
"Well, it's just gonna
be like last time, sure,
I might try a little bit,
I might fail a little bit,
but I just got to keep
chipping away at that thing,
and before I know it, I'm gonna
be able to get through it."
So that's the best advice.
And actually there's a
ton of research on that,
that those who are willing
to embrace failure,
those were willing to step
out of their comfort zone
and learn from it, who defined themselves
not by the outcome by success or failure,
but who defined themselves by,
"Hey, I'm someone who's
always willing to try,
I'm someone who's always
willing to do the hard thing."
Those are the people who
do really well in life
without fail, (laughs)
not to overuse the word.
So let's see, from
Instagram, it's me Shreash,
asks, how was your graduation day?
So actually I've had
several graduation days,
high school and then undergrad
and then from business school,
I would say I've already described
my high school graduation
a little bit.
I have to say graduation days
have been unusually eventful for me.
So when I was in college,
I was my senior class president at MIT,
so I was on the commencement committee.
And at the time the President
of the United States
was Bill Clinton.
So you can imagine when we
used to have our meetings
for the commencement committee,
this was in November of my senior year,
this was in 1997, we
had these meetings like,
"Who should we invite for commencement?"
And the previous year Al Gore had spoken,
and so I was just like,
" Why don't we invite the
president of the United States?"
(laughs)
I was just thinking, why not?
See if the president will show up.
And the Vice President
showed up a year before.
And I remember President Vest,
who was the President of
MIT at the time, said,
"Sal, first of all,
there's no way the
president's gonna to show up.
Second of all, it's a bit
of a pain with the security
chuckles) and all logistics."
And even though the Vice
PResident was pretty tough,
the president would be even harder.
So anyway, I'm like, "All right."
So we actually did invite, that
year's time man of the year
was someone by the name of David Ho,
who helped develop some of
the antivirals that helped
kind of cure AIDS.
So big deal time man of the year
was our commencement speaker.
I was excited about that.
And so you fast forward to about,
I think it was like three
days before commencement,
and I get an email from
President Vest saying,
"Sal, are you okay with this?"
And it was a forward from the White House.
And it said, "President Clinton
would like to give a
major speech or whatever
on the digital divide
at MIT's commencement.
And he would he's
inviting himself (laughs)
to be the commencement speaker."
And so I just responded back, I was like,
"Yeah, I'm cool with this."
And so (chuckles) he ended up
being our commencement speaker
with a few days notice,
and then it was literally,
Oh, no, it was more than that,
it was now that I remember,
that email was actually
probably about a month before
commencement because obviously
all of the logistics,
and then the night before
commencement was actually
when I got the other email
from President Vest saying,
"Are you okay with this?"
And it said that "President
Clinton has some time
and might be coming an hour early
and would like to meet
with a few student leaders"
And so this was just one
of these random things
where it was me and six
other student leaders,
we got to spend an an hour
with the President of United States
right before our graduation.
Regardless of your political affiliation,
regardless of anything,
it's a pretty heady experience
if you're 21 years old to graduation day
and the President United States
wants to hang out with you
before graduation for an hour.
And it really was kind
of like hanging out,
it was really weird.
I ended a good way.
'Cause you normally think
these people are some,
you don't realize there are people too.
So it was a fascinating conversation.
And then right when we were
all getting out of the door,
ready to go line up for
commencement President Clinton says,
"I think I have a little
bit of time after my speech.
I would like to give
a couple of student
leaders their diplomas."
And so I gave my little two minutes speech
as class president, then President Clinton
gave his digital divide speech,
then David Ho gave his speech.
So we had two commencement speakers,
and then President Clinton
gave me and three other people,
our diplomas, and then he got
on his helicopter and left.
So that was ... (chuckles)
I was like, "Wow, how did that happen?"
It was definitely a
powerful experience for me.
And once again, regardless
of where you are
on the political spectrum,
regardless of anything,
when you're young
and you realize that there's
these people who have done,
who are very influential in the world
that they are still human beings
and that you can connect
with them and talk to them.
It did open my operatory,
it did make me think,
okay, wow, maybe this is a world
in which I too might have
something to contribute.
So you can't discount
something like that."
So that was a very powerful experience.
So let's see, Instagram, Kayondo.
How did you feel right after
graduating from college?
So this is an interesting question.
I actually, there's a
little bit of excitement
that you're graduating from college,
that all those problem sets
and deadlines (chuckles)
and all of those things that
college academic rat race
is a little bit over, but
I have to, in hindsight,
I realized that it was sad
because so much of your identity,
your friendships, they're all at college.
And I was excited I was going
to move out to California
for a job, my first job was gonna be
a product manager at Oracle.
And I was excited about that,
but I didn't know anyone
out in Northern California.
And so when I came out here,
I have to admit, it was tough.
I tell a lot of folks that
first year out of college
going to a place where
I didn't know anyone,
I didn't have any really good friends,
I spent a lot of nights (chuckles)
just hanging out at the
Barnes and Nobles (chuckles)
reading books for free.
(laughs)
That was my social life.
It wasn't the best year for
me, it was a tough year.
And then slowly ...
What happened was I had a lot of friends
who we were with,
and I finished my degree
a little bit early,
so I came out a year earlier.
And so when more of my friends
came out the next year,
then it started to get
a little bit better.
But that first year out of college,
I think it can be a little bit jarring,
'cause I was fortunate, I had a good job,
I had a good boss, I had good coworkers,
but it's still not the
same thing as what you get
when you're in the dorm
room pontificating things,
doing silly things that you do in college.
Still when I get together
with my college friends,
we reminisce about a lot
of the silliness (chuckles)
that happened in college.
So yeah, it was tough,
but then slowly but surely
it got better as more and more friends,
and I met new people,
and it is all about keeping
an open mind to things,
to new people
and to not just grieving
for what you might've lost.
And then, but I was eager to
go back to business school
because business school
had a little bit of
that element as well.
Just the sense of community,
et cetera, et cetera.
And then after business
school, by that point,
I had a fiance, so I
was feeling less lonely.
(laughs)
So I post business school
life felt pretty good.
And then she married me.
So Instagram, Aiden Jaffa Rover says,
"What do you wish you would have known
when you graduated from high school?"
I think, I was a reasonably,
I'm fundamentally an introverted person.
Like if I go to a big
dinner party I'll enjoy it,
but then I like to come
home and just decompress
and have quiet time for myself,
that's when I re-energize.
And even when I went to college
and actually in high school as well,
I always did have the mindset that,
Hey, I wanna step out of my comfort zone,
I wanna try new things,
I wanna try to meet new
people and be open to things.
But I think especially in high school
and to a lesser degree in college,
but especially in high school,
it's very easy to get
into your head and saying,
"Oh, well, they probably don't really,
wouldn't be interested in hanging out
or they're in that
crowd, I'm in this crowd,
we're friendly,
but we really wouldn't get
a lot from each other."
And I think that's a mistake.
I think you actually have the chance
to get the most from the
folks in your high school
and in your college that
are different from you.
I now realize in hindsight,
and I've met many of these
people now that we're adults,
and everyone has those same
insecurities, everyone.
I don't care who it is.
It could be the the captain
of the football team,
the homecoming King, Queen.
Everyone's oftentimes some
of them will have more
of those insecurities
because they're afraid
their identity is so defined
by some of these things,
these external things.
And so I think if you're an open person
who's genuinely interested
in other people,
you can form deeper
connections with anyone
and they will appreciate it.
And even on first cut,
they might be even a
little bit weirded out.
I mean, you don't do
things that are truly scary
(chuckles) but if you're like,
"Hey, do you need anything?"
"Hey, I wanna help you."
"Hey, tell me about your family."
At first, you're like,
"Why are people asking?
is he interested in me?"
But then people are like,
"Oh, well, you wanna know?
I'll tell you."
And I think those deep
connections are super powerful.
I think another thing
that I wish I knew better
in high school is that, it's
easy to treat your teachers
as teachers and only teachers.
And I did form, I would say a friendship
with a handful of teachers,
Mr. Hernandez, Miss Kennedy,
are the ones in high school
that definitely come to mind
that I could talk to about things.
And they would talk to me about stuff.
It was really powerful.
They treated me more like a peer,
and obviously sometimes
they had to play teacher
and I was a student, but a lot of times
there was a nice comradery between us.
But I think for other times
it was very easy to say,
"Oh, so and so, that teacher is like this.
They like to fail students
and they're like that."
And in hindsight, I
realized how wrong it is
because 99.99999% of
the teachers that I had,
and that I'm sure you have,
their number one priority
was to try to prepare you
for the world,
and make you a better human being.
And I wish, I told you
the story of me having a,
bringing a guitar to graduation.
(chuckles)
So you can imagine every now and then
I wasn't probably the easiest student
to have in your classroom.
And so one of the things
I wish I did was also,
for even some of the teachers
that I felt weren't
aligned with my worldview,
I wish that I had reached out to them more
and figured out how I could support them,
and also tell them how much,
what they did meant to me
and to our peers and how
much we grew from it.
I have to say, even some of those,
you always have your favorites
and then you have those
teachers and you're like,
"Oh, they're so hard,
and they're just trying
to stick it to us."
But I gotta tell you when
you're 40, 42, 43 years old,
(chuckles) like myself, I
get together with friends.
I was like, "That way we
learned a lot in that class."
(chuckles)
And so and so teacher
really, by being hard on us,
prepared us, like prepared us for life.
So those are some of the
things that I wish I had known.
And to just know that it all works out,
it really all works out,
that everything that you
stress about in the moment,
usually a week later, a month
later, for sure, a year later,
you won't even remember what the thing was
that you were worried about.
And I still remind myself that
'cause every now and
then I do have something
where I wake up in the middle of the night
and I'm like, "Oh, why is that happening?
And why ... And then I remind, Sal,
you've gone through
this like 500 times now,
it's not gonna matter.
(laughs)
It's not gonna matter in the long run,
just do what you can, be an open person,
be an optimistic person
and the universe will
hopefully give you back
some of that optimism
and openness as well,
and things will resolve themselves.
So those are some of the things.
So some of the stress was unnecessary
and some of the anxiety and
some of the insecurities,
in fact, all of it was
(laughs) unnecessary.
I wish I had meditated.
I picked that up about two years ago.
I wish I had started
even 10 minutes a day,
because then all of the stuff
that I just talked about
it would have just, it's
like Rain-X for your soul,
(laughs) things just beat up and fall off,
they don't absorb
(chuckles) into your mind.
From Instagram, Louisa Montavonnie asks,
Hi Sal, what are tips to decide
what you want to study in university?
So my advice is don't steer
type yourself too much.
I think it's very easy for us,
sometimes we get little positive feedback
from one teacher or another
in one subject or another
saying, "Oh, I'm a writer
or I'm a programmer,
or I'm a math person."
And they say, "I'm gonna to be a writer,
or I'm gonna be an art historian"
Because of that feedback.
And that might be the case,
and those might all be great fields.
But I think it depends
where you go to school,
but in the U.S. there's a lot
of opportunity to try things,
especially your freshman year.
So I would take courses
in a pretty very thing,
I would ... The other thing I wish I knew
is a lot of professors don't mind it.
I used to think, Hey, there's
200 kids in this room.
The professor has no
interest talking to me,
but I wish I had at least tried.
Sometimes I did talk to the
professor in smaller classes,
but in those large
classes, I was always like,
"Oh, I'm just gonna go do
my thing, they don't ...
But oftentimes you can talk to them,
especially if you're genuinely interested.
There's some students who
are not genuinely interested
and they're just trying to
suck up to the professor
(laughs) to maybe get an A,
but there are also students
are genuinely interested.
And if you are genuinely
interested in the course
and the subject matter,
the professor will probably
want to talk to you
and might even have an internship for you
or have advice about for you.
And so I would do that.
I would talk to as many people,
I would talk to as many
upperclassmen as you can find,
ask them as many questions,
especially the upperclassmen,
the seniors who are getting jobs,
ask sometimes a little
bit sensitive questions,
how much are you getting paid?
(chuckles)
What does the job offer?
What does the job market
look like in that major?
And then if you can, find
to get a hold of alarms,
people who graduated the last few years,
because sometimes the work
that you do in the major
is different than the work
that you do in the job.
And so talk to the alarms
who majored in X and say,
"Okay, you got a job,
don't hurt to ask him,
how much money do you get paid?
"How hard do you have to work?"
All of that, but then ask,
"What does the actual work like?
What surprised you about it?
What surprise you about that work?"
And you'll learn a lot.
I have to say if there's one thing that,
and I didn't do it well early on,
but by my junior and
senior year and in college,
and for sure, my second
year in business school,
that's what I did, (chuckles)
I was very shameless.
I remember I really enjoyed
a capital markets class,
which is all about the stock
market and the bond market
and how money moves through the world.
And it was a pretty math, heavy class.
And in business school, I went at HBS,
the math,
a lot of students didn't
go super deep in the math.
And so I oftentimes was
the closer, so to speak,
where the professor would say,
"Sal, how do we solve this equation?"
And so I had a good relationship
with that professor,
his name was George Taco, and I said,
"George, I love this class.
What can I do in life
that is like this class?"
And he said, "Well, you should
go work at a hedge fund."
And I said, "That sounds awesome.
What is a hedge fund?"
(chuckles)
And then he explained,
"It's like a mutual fund,
but they can do more exotic things,
they have more flexibility
in how they invest,
but they're regulated differently."
So I was like, "Okay, that's interesting."
And then I looked at all my classmates
who had worked in finance,
and then I started going to that.
I was like, "What's a hedge fund?
How much do you get paid?
What's the lifestyle like?"
And then I was like, "Oh, this
sounds good at least to me. "
And then I started going
through the job search process.
So that wasn't picking the major,
but I was picking the career.
But the same process is
true on the major side.
Just ask a ton of questions,
don't be afraid to ask about money.
Sometimes on university
campuses money can be viewed
as a little bit of a ghost
so, "Oh, we're academics.
How dare you talk about career and money?"
(chuckles)
No, talk about money (chuckles)
Money for sure isn't everything in life,
but you need to be able
to put food on the table,
support yourself, pay off your debt.
If you're not able to
do that kind of stuff,
you're not gonna be able to
do the high-minded stuff.
So I'm not saying you have
to become a millionaire
or even have to become a fluent,
but it's super important to think about,
am I picking a major that
I have a decent chance
of getting a job that I
enjoy, not just tolerate,
but I can enjoy and I can pay off my debt,
and have a reasonable chance
of saving for a down payment
on a house, and being
able to go on vacations,
and if I choose to have a family,
to send my kids to college in the future.
So I don't think it's ever
too early to think about that.
All right, so these are great,
maybe we'll do another one of these,
whenever we don't have a guest.
Maybe this will be graduation season
'cause I don't know if y'all,
I'm enjoying playing uncle Sal right now.
(chuckles)
So this is ...
So YouTube, first guy, Gomez asks,
what would you have done differently
if you could start college over again?
It's the same, and I'll finish on this
'cause I just realized
I think I do have a call
that I can't reschedule (chuckles)
starting in a minute ago.
If I could start college over again,
it's the same advice that I said,
I would be that much more open.
I would be, if someone has helped me,
if they mean something to me,
I would have told them that,
I would have stepped out of my
comfort zone that much more.
And I did step out of my comfort zone.
When I was, my freshman year in college,
I intentionally joined
the improv comedy troupe
because I was like,
"There's nothing like stepping
out of your comfort zone,
like improv comedy (chuckles)
And we had to travel around
from school to school
and people would shout out
a noun, a verb, a setting,
and context and you'd have to act it out
and try to be somewhat humorous.
(laughs)
So there's nothing like improv comedy
that will teach you to be
out of your comfort zone.
But I wish I would have done more of that.
And I would have been more
open with my thoughts,
my emotions, my insecurities,
because that's the type of thing
that forms the
connections-deeper friendships.
And I came out of college
with great friendships,
and I feel very fortunate front.
I met my wife in college ,
but I think there could
have been even more.
And even to this day, once a
month I probably have a dream
about college, where I'm in
one of these circumstances,
a lot of it's like the end of the term
and I forgot to drop a class and I'm like,
"Oh my God."
Whatever.
But anyway, thanks everyone
for being part of this.
I think this worked out doing
the Instagram and the Facebook
and YouTube at the same time.
And I just wanna thank
everyone for joining this,
And I'm gonna go jump onto that call now.
See, how do I turn this?